the animal foundation announcing a pause  on all adoptions all transfers and  fosters until further notice in a  statement on Twitter the foundation said  that 16 dogs at their shelter are  dealing with a respiratory illness those  dogs are on antibiotics the organization  saying the decision comes from advice  from their Veterinary team and an  abundance of caution we can also tell  you that the shelter has been operating  at or over capacity now for several  months in fact the foundation faced a  contagious outbreak back in 2007 in that  case more than a thousand animals had to  be euthanized that outbreak led to  sweeping changes which eventually helped  the animal foundation work toward  becoming a no-kill shelter just a couple  of years ago